من عمان نرحب باللواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك معنا سيد
فايز اذا اوكرانيا تحاول خرق الدفاعات
الاماميه الروسيه برايك الى اي مدى
استطاعت هجماتها اليوم بالمسيرات
بالوصول الى هذا الهدف
يعني اذا تتبعنا تلك الغارات بدءا من
الهجوم على قاعده انجلز مرورا بقبه
الكرملين
وصولا الى كيرش وغير ذلك هذا يؤكد ان هناك
انتقاء دقيقا للاهداء لماذا
لان التاثير المادي المباشر محدود
فبالتالي يجب ان يكون هناك تاثيرا موازيا
وهذا هو ما تعمل عليه اوكرانيا في
الجغرافيا الروسيه بينما في شبه جزيره
القرم هي تبحث عن التاثير المادي اكثر من
التاثيرات المرافقه بينما في العمق الروسي
لا عندما تصل طائره وتقصف قاعده انجلز
وتخرج او تحدث اصابات ببعض طائرات
استراتيجيه عندما تصل الى قبه الكريم سواء
نجحت او اخفقت عندما تصل الى ابراج موسكو
اذا
لها ارتداداتها وتاثيراتها في المستويات
التي ذكرناها كثيرا السياسيه الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه الامنيه ودعني فقط اركز على
البعد السياسي بالعمس كان هناك
تغريده
للرئيس السابق نائب رئيس مجلس القومي
سيد مدبيد ماذا تحدث
وكنا نلاحظ في العباره انه
يعاني من هذه الاختراقات وبالتالي بدا
بالحديث عن تفكيك اوكرانيا واذا ما شابه
ذلك لماذا هذا الالم في هذا الكلام بسبب
التاثيرات المرافقه وليست التاثيرات
الماديه الناتجه اذا اختيار الهدف كان له
مغزى وحقق بعضا من اهدافه هناك حرص على
القول ان هذه المسيرات هي صناعه محليه
اوكرانيه ما هو الاتفاق مع دول الغرب فيما
يخص اسلحتها التي تدعم بها
اوكرانيا بمعنى
ما الذي لا يجب فيه استخدام هذه الاسلحه
حسب الاتفاق مع هذه الدول
يعني امريكا تحديدا هي التي وضعت الخطوط
الحمراء بان ما تزود به اوكرانيا يجب ان
لا يستخدم داخل الجغرافيا الروسيه حتى لا
يكون كاوراق ضغط اضافيه تجبر روسيا على رد
فعل معين لان التلويح باستخدام القنابل
النوويه التكتيكيه كانت على لسان اكثر من
مسؤول واكثر من خبير واكثر من محلل روسي
رغم اننا نستبعد حدوث ذلك لكن دعني اشير
على سبيل المثال هي مارس
تم التزويد بقذائف تصل الى 80 كيلو متر
ولم يتم التزويد بقذائف 300 كيلو متر
والتكامس 250 كيلو متر لم تصل بعد لكن
هناك البدائل من الدول الاوروبيه والتي
بدات توظيفه لا اقول داخل الجغرافيا
الروسيه لكن توظيف المدى ظل العاصفه
وبالتالي هذا استخدم اكثر مره من قبل سلاح
الجو الاوكراني اذا الخط الاحمر عدم
استخدامها الان فيما يتعلق بالطائرات
المسيره الصناعه المحليه هناك شركات
مختصه تم رصد مبلغ عشر ملايين دولار
كباكج اولي وهناك
تسارع جاد في انتاج انواع متعدده وبعضها
يصل مدى الى اكثر من ثمان مئه كيلو متر
وهي التي هاجمت قاعده انجلز سيد فايز
اوكرانيا اليوم تعول على الحصول على
الطائرات نوعيه مثل اف 16 الامريكيه
السويديه في حال حصولها على هذه الطائرات
كيف ستتغير اوجه الحرب وهل ستتمكن من حسم
المعركه لصالحها
يعني الان الاجابه ليست بنعم او لا او
تؤثر او لا تؤثر الاجابه تقع ضمن المنطقه
الرماديه لماذا لا اتحدث هنا عن اعداد
عن فقط نوع الطائره يجب ان اتحدث عن
منظومه متكامله طائره الاف 16 اللي هي
طائره التفوق الجوي وهي طائره بيعه منها
اكثر من 4500 طائره في 25 دوله في العالم
هذه الطائره كرقم
ليس ذلك المعنى الكبير انما هل هي ضمن
حزمه متكامله من البنيه التحتيه من النظام
اللوجستيك لانها طائره معقده تحتاج الى
صيانه تواجه مشاكل من حيث العدم اذا يجب
ان تكون كافه الطواقم على اهبه الاستعداد
وعلى نفس السويه وكذلك الاعداد التي تصل
هل نتحدث عن خمس طائرات الدفعه الاولى من
الطيارين ست طيارين
هذا الرقم هل يغير في الموازين لا سئلت
قبل ذلك ما هو الرقم الذي يجب ان يصل حتى
نستطيع الجزم بان سيكون تاثيرا فاعلا وانا
تقديرات كمحلل اقول يجب ان لا تقل عن خمسه
الى سته اشراق وفي بعض الحالات الخمسه
اشرار تعادل 100 طائره لان السرب 12 18 24
طائره وحسب
المهام التي يوظف لها وحسب التنظيم
الهيكلي لتلك الدول اذا هي تحتاج الى 100
طائره سواء الطائره السويديه او طائره اف
16 عند ذلك نقول علينا ان نتوقع تاثيرا
ملموسا حاسما لان نقطه الضعف والتي ادت
الى لا اقول افشال انما عدم تمكن الهجوم
المضاد من تحقيق انجازات كما كان الكل
يتوقع غياب الاسناد الجوي وعدم
التحقيق السيطره الجويه المحليه في الحد
الادنى شكرا لك من عمان اللواء فايزه
دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي